welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul
and this video we're breaking down tan
the the stand yeah
it's it's it's just done now the fourth
episode is now out and there's a lot to
unpack from it
including a little stephen king cameo i
felt like this episode was a bit all
over the place because of the time jumps
but i'm still enjoying the show though i
know it's getting a lot of backlash
now the episode opens with franny
writing a journal which sort of becomes
an aesthetic of this entry
throughout she discusses how 75 000
years ago
that humanity was on the verge of
extinction and how
these people struggled on which led to
the species thriving once more
it's a hopeful message and one that sort
of drives the people in this entry
at this point we pretty much know all of
the main characters in the show
and the introduction sees them
assembling for a council meeting
we see larry pouring his pills down the
drain which symbolizes that he's
accepted his role in authority
the other characters also get dressed
including harold
who though not part of the team picks
out a suit and dresses in his sunday
best
there's a great shot on the show when
he's putting it all together in the
mirror
like several of the other characters but
where harold differs is that he has a
photograph in his
this has tom cruise pointing and
laughing at him which certainly hints to
us that the men in society that are seen
as something special
mock and dislike him throughout the
episode his hate of stew grows ever more
apparent
and i love the way that it's set up here
by old tommy boy basically carrying this
out to his reflection
in the background we can also hear the
song don't take your guns to town
by johnny cash the song tells the story
of a mother who warns his son about
taking his guns to town
and how it could cause a situation he
ignores this advice
does it anyway and goes to a saloon
where he's shot and killed in a gunfight
so lots of things going on in this such
as how
putting up in a front often leads to
others trying to match it
and this creates escalation it can be
applied to several things in the entry
such as randall flags sending a message
which caused the council to send people
out to spy on him
however it can also be applied to them
going out as its obvious flag will
become aware of their actions
and will of course do something back
mother abigail wants against carrying
out this action
and she could be very much seen as a
stand-in for the mother
in this song and that's why i'm the
bloody best breakdown guy on the net
folks
thumbs up buttons right there now at the
meeting the citizens have a lot of
questions about the crucified man
and we see how stu falls apart under
pressure
however larry who's used to public
speaking gets up
and rallies everyone together around the
positive things that they've managed to
achieve
he gets several people to stand up and
take a bow
including nadine cross now the fact that
she's a teacher means she has a lot of
influence
over the youth and i think flag might
have even pushed her into this role
throughout her life
so she could be a force that manipulated
young minds
in the book the planchette scene didn't
happen until she was already at college
pursuing a teaching degree
but the change could have been put in
place last episode to hint that flag has
a control
over all the actions throughout her life
they also discuss
turning the power back on which becomes
pivotal in this entry
intercut with his meeting is the council
debating whether they should discuss
flag in vegas
however they downplay it and pretend
it's not bad and it sounds like some
country's pandemic response but
we will not go into that now you may
also notice that fran is dressed very
similar and showing much in the same way
that she was in glenn's painting from
last week
cementing that his dream did indeed come
true
another important addition comes when
the body crew get changed to the city
watch
harold also gets people to vote on the
council becoming the permanent members
and this of course plays into flag's
overall plan to have them
in place so that he can take them out
all in one fell swoop
upon returning home he's greeted by the
kind of woman that you wouldn't want to
find on your doorstep late at night
and aiding seduces him into joining her
on flag's ranks
flag of course has been sowing the seeds
of doubt in harold's mind
and cross turns on the charm in order to
win him around
he dodges a bullet and finds a way of
not going to bed with her before she can
poop in it
but it's clear that he's now very much
on her own flag's side
now as she states she is a virgin and
will remain that way
as a quote unquote unbroken vessel for
when she meets flack
by the way yeah that's not me using the
phrase unbroken vessel because i'm some
mentalist
it's what she refers to as her virginity
in the book anyway
we cut to two months earlier and you see
harold having another experience with a
woman
namely fran he professes his love to her
and she rejects his advances
which is the complete opposite to the
nadine situation
in which he was throwing herself at him
in the first episode we saw that he had
written a story about two people that
had been pushed together at the end of
the world
and it's crystal clear that he believes
that his fantasy has come true
he's obviously scorned by the rejection
and we also catch up with glenn and stew
who are following the signs he left
behind they don't come a moment too soon
either
as on the road fran and harold are
ambushed by a man named garvey
played by angus simpson you might
recognize him from both the walking dead
mad max and insidious now this
confrontation
differs slightly from the book as here
he's working by himself
in the source material things are a lot
darker
as he's part of a group that kidnap and
torture women
now if you watched our video last week
you might remember that we talked about
how stu joined fran and harold the same
time that he met him
so he doesn't show up like some knight
in shining armor
when it comes to the source material so
yeah lots of changes and the book is
actually
far worse than what we see on screen
even though this meeting is pretty
chilling
i was actually expecting harold to pull
a gun out from an ankle holster
as stu said last week that he noticed
the character had one
but alas this is missing from the fight
scene both versions see garvey being
taken out
and were also introduced to dana jurgens
who has a really big scene down the line
when it comes to las vegas after all
they've been through
on the night stew offers them an
alliance after divulging that they all
have the same dreams
harold once more seems to want to pee on
his ideas
but glenn steps forward and does what
he's best at
which is of course talking he says that
in the past people didn't believe in the
bible because there was no proof
however they've started to see things
that have some legitimacy to them
through abigail
and it's worth joining together franny
gets up in the middle of the night
and with stew they discuss flag as well
as glenn's painting which told them that
fran was pregnant
we learned that harold doesn't even know
and along with not discussing the shared
dreams
it's clear they don't really have the
relationship that harold thought they
did
we then cut to the present and stu
talking to the city watch
unlike the council meeting he commands
the crowd dishes out instructions
and is loved by pretty much everyone
other than harold
this clearly pushes harold to hate him
even more as he's everything that he
isn't
he's naturally friendly whereas harold
isn't
he's liked by people whereas harold
isn't and he has a relationship with
fran
whereas harold doesn't inside the pocket
of his jacket he finds a leaflet given
to the ski patrol
which details that the group have access
to explosive charges
and this of course sets up what's to
come now i actually really appreciated
this
as in the book it's not really detailed
how nadine or harold get the dynamite
however they do a good job of filling in
how they come to possess them
which leaves an age-old plot hole
finally filled in we also see the
friendship of terry and harold in more
depth
as they hope and pray that the rock is
still alive
my lord plea please still be alive rock
now whilst harold starts to piece
together his plan
the committee start to put together a
sort of black ops team
dana does the old you you know the one
list all the bad things about the
mission and how stupid it is before
saying
you son of a [ __ ] i mean judge faris is
also recruited
and they've done a gender swap on the
character which will have some
ramifications for the way things play
out down the line
there's also an interesting take with
tom cullen as
in the source material he was actually
hypnotized so that his cover story
wouldn't slip
yeah it's a lot more simple and he just
says
m-o-o-n and that spells you son of a
[ __ ] i'm in
from here we jump back to his journey
with nick on the road and sort of get
more of their backstory the pair are set
upon by julie laurie in a shopping
center
and similar to the nadine scene she
tries to seduce nick
he rejects her advances and i think this
has been put in place to show
just how much of an opposite that he is
to harold nick couldn't be controlled by
flag
or a woman and thus he's more fitting to
be on mother abigail's side
the scene is changed from the book as in
that the pair have sex
whereas here a lot more of their more
in-depth moments are skipped over in the
work she even slashes the pair's
motorbike tires
and tries to snipe them from afar
similar to what we see here
julie has a really nasty side to her in
the source material
and she's also mentally unstable this
meeting is very important
and if you've seen the mini series or
read the book then you'll know she's a
key player in the events to come
now unwittingly she leads them to an
advert for hemingford home
which just so happens to have a picture
of stephen king on it
and what i'm guessing is gonna be his
only cameo in the season
the bear head towards it and it's here
that they meet mother abigail for the
first time
now you may notice that there's a
chinese checkerboard in one of the
establishing
shots typically there are multi-coloured
pieces that accompany this
but i think the black and white tier has
been used to denote the battle between
flag and abigail
all those around her have died and she
talks to a dead woman named gloria
showing that her sanity has slipped
slightly
in the present abigail makes it clear
that they must wait for god's
instructions before taking action
against flag
but nick has clearly disobeyed this he
says his goodbyes to tom
and it's a really touching moment i
think their friendship is actually one
of the strongest parts of this season
and it was a really emotional goodbye
that you know
it makes me sad seeing him right off i
like the guy now this is the good guy's
plan
and we then cut in 18 and harold and
acting theirs
they discover the explosives whilst the
town also prepared to turn the power
back
on this actually goes well and it
juxtaposes the source material
which saw the grid being overloaded due
to a lot of things still being switched
on
however it goes off without a hitch and
also allows
larry to jam away on his guitar to the
crowd now across the town we see teddy
stumble upon nadine and harold he thinks
he's in there at first but
as i said earlier she's not the type of
person you want to bump into
during the night i'll let you decide
whether whether i'm talking about nadine
ramba there
and she shoots and kills him now the
character did die
in the book but weirdly it actually
happened after this event
you may remember that earlier in the
season harold saved his life by holding
him in his arms
and his death goes in a similar sort of
way with the character clutching him
as he passes away that ends the episode
and
a big question left in the air is what
are they going to do to cover up this
murder
as i mentioned teddy dies a different
point in the book so that they don't
really have to scramble around to hide
his body
and it is going to be interesting to see
what they do to hide the crime
let me know your thoughts below and of
course on the episode as a whole yet did
you like it
or did you not now as a thank you for
interacting with this video you'll be
entered into a prize straw where we're
giving away three copies of the hobbit
and lord of the rings 4k box set to our
subscribers
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like the video make sure
you subscribe with notifications on and
drop a comment below with your thoughts
on the episode
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the series so far
as we go over the things you missed give
our theories
and also just talk about the differences
from the book if not then you know what
i don't hate yet i hope you have a good
week
and thanks for watching the video i've
been paul and i'll see you next time
take care peace